e
[Musique]
silence en fait aux valises un voyage
vous attend le rappeur hippocampe vous
entraîne dans ses rêves 80 à travers le
monde vélo cazaux début de faire des
recherches ne serait ce que sur les
instruments de différents lieux sur les
sur peut-être les étés formules
rythmiques sur l'harmonie sur des choses
comme ça voulait sortir un petit peu de
deux structures actuelles quoi de faire
de fer pouvoir râpé par exemple sur des
sur des rythmiques un peu particulière
ou sur les harmonies étrangers des
choses comme ça quoi c'était un
challenge une oeuvre né d'une rencontre
le batteur lucas d'aurier lance l'idée
il ya six ans il peut qu'un fou les deux
artistes habitués des concerts veulent
créer une pièce qui mêle musique et
vidéo
[Musique]
première idée c'était quoi c'était de
mélanger la musique du monde avec le hip
hop et après avoir listé un petit peu
tous les tous les pays où tous les
genres musicaux qu'on pouvait mélanger
on s'est dit avec tout ça on peut
raconter une histoire et avoir fait le
scénario de spectacle de la terre à la
lune l'odyssée d'ipo s'inspire aussi du
monde de la musique de film
une mise en scène épurée pour laisser
parler les partitions et vidéos
hippocampe vous vous entraîne avec
gourmandise dans ses aventures